[Music]
[Applause]
sequence here watch this around
Pavel dishes back Tiffany steps in front
gets the ball back and the LOB to O'Neal
and how about Shaq's reaction
[Applause]
razzle Passover tuning legs
from the crowd better hassle with five
to shoot
way behind in fact pretty place spinning
shop
what a shot by Twain way
directions beautiful move by way waves
finding an open area inside drives hard
jaws
[Applause]
and then the finish how about the finish
of flip facts with the
on the spin of the ball
well what a duck by train wait that's
highly edgy
Superman wears number three at Miami
cleared for takeoff and lookout Abeka
Okafor's coming right at you
five seconds left Raiders back to Twin
shoots now I couldn't get it off that
fires it up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in his final game against the Golden
State Warriors Dwyane Wade beats the
Warriors
[Applause]
watch the extension of the body
[Applause]
this way us will be a factor out of our
other
[Applause]
[Applause]
wait one of the fathers
welcome to your Kodak moment everything
goes out whip six not a good matchup
right here for the heat Salvage wave of
the steel with June
put you left for the web
[Applause]
incredible we are witnessing one of the
great players ever play in this league
and man I hope it lasts another seven
eight nine years baby what up at you boy
Adam left coach you like that content I
know you like that concept hit subscribe
for more of it from Bleacher Report